hi I'm fair and cousin sitting in for
David Pakman this week and this is the
David Pakman show
David is on vacation I'll be sitting
here with you for the next few days
there's a lot to talk about so let's
jump right into it I think one of the
biggest things obviously that's been
happening over the course of the last
few days and no it doesn't involve the
president coloring a flag wrong or not
lowering a flag to half-mast it actually
involves the president trying to
interfere with the FBI and the DOJ
starting late last week Donald Trump
tweeted out in response to Jeff's
session saying he wasn't going to let
his DOJ become politicized politics were
not gonna influence what he was doing so
the president gets on Twitter and he
says the following here he says Jeff
Sessions said he wouldn't allow politics
to influence him only because he doesn't
understand what is happening underneath
his command position highly conflicted
Bob Muller and his gang of 17 angry Dems
are having a field day as real
corruption goes untouched no collusion
the no collusion part at the end seemed
a little odd didn't really apply to what
he was saying but sure throw it in there
whatever then later on he tweeted out
that the FBI ignored hundreds of
thousands of emails from Hillary Clinton
and he issued this ominous warning at
the end of that sweida said at some
point I may have to get involved at some
point I may have to get involved let me
tell you my little theory about
everything that's going on right now
with the president and his angry
incorrect tweets first and foremost he
is laying the framework to fire Jeff
Sessions now it's not because he
absolutely just hates Jeff Sessions I
mean he's not happy that the guy recused
himself from any of these investigations
but Jeff Sessions for the most part has
been carrying water for this
administration you know he put together
Donald Trump's family separation policy
for him he has been a good little sermon
except in this one particular area so
Donald Trump wants to get rid of him
that he can eventually replace him with
somebody who will fire Robert Muller or
replace him or remove him or otherwise
interfere with that investigation that
is the goal here it's not that he's mad
at sessions it's that he wants someone
who's going to make this other
investigation go away so by coming out
and telling us that the FBI dropped the
ball on the Hillary Clinton
investigation or that there was
collusion among the Democrats with
foreign powers he's trying to get his
followers to buy into the idea that
something's not right with the Democrats
but Jeff Sessions won't investigate them
something has to be done we're letting
them get away with massive corruption
and that is the framework that he's
creating right now now we all know
there's no basis in reality for any of
this yeah the FBI didn't look at
thousands of emails probably because
they weren't relevant we know that they
investigated that we know the
Republicans have investigated Benghazi
to the moon and back and they couldn't
come up with a single thing with which
to charge Hillary Clinton for all right
it's over let it go it's done I don't
care what your opinion is of Hillary
Clinton or any of that a woman has been
investigated probably more than any
other sitting politician at this point
they couldn't get her on anything so let
it go and no it's not because we had
corrupt investigative services the FBI
wasn't corrupted just because one dude
happened to favor her who has now been
fired no the only reason Trump is
talking about this is because he needs a
reason that will play well with his base
to fire Jeff Sessions and again the
firing of sessions is only to get to
robert muller basically send a shot
across the bow unfortunately for donald
trump it's really not going to play out
the way he thinks it is because here's
what's gonna happen republicans have
made it clear that they would not
appoint or approve confirm a new it
general before the midterms so you're
gonna get an acting Attorney General
most likely rod Rosenstein well we all
know Trump hates Rosenstein so what's he
gonna do at that point
fire Rosenstein as well just keep going
through that entire line of succession
until he finds the right man or woman
willing to interfere with the Muller
investigation that's not possible it's
going to make him look desperate
so at this point his hands are really
tied not to mention the fact that even
though Jeff Sessions has lost some
friends in the US Senate particularly
Lindsey Graham he still has buddies
there I keep in mind this is a very
tight-knit close group of people there's
only 100 people at any given point out
of the entire US population of more than
330 million only 100 serving as US
senators jeff Sessions was one of those
people for I believe a little over two
decades everybody they're his friends
they still have lunch together on
occasion they're not gonna take so
kindly to Donald Trump firing him they
might we they've proven over over the
last few months that they are completely
spineless that they're not willing to
stand up to the president when he does
these awful things but eventually
there's gonna come a breaking point for
these folks there has to it's human
nature something will happen something
will come down from the president one
scandal will be too big for them to talk
down and they'll have to eventually turn
on it it may come before the midterms
most likely it's going to come after the
midterms but either way firing Jeff
Sessions would be the catalyst that a
few of these Republicans need to finally
say enough is enough and again it is
there's a little humor in it as I
mentioned before Jeff Sessions has done
every horrible thing that Donald Trump
is wanted him to do and then some
you know his war on marijuana out there
that wasn't something Trump asked him to
do that's just his backwards 1940s
political think
work so the one good thing Jeff Sessions
does which is recuse himself from the
investigation that could actually end up
getting him fired the one time he wasn't
a completely backwards politician the
one time he did the right thing and now
he may end up paying the price for it
because Donald Trump is terrified of the
Muller investigation